to the just pearly things you can't do
on it yeah you're in it it's live now is
it
on oh does it like yeah keep it on here
so what happens if we're live on youtube
so anyone like people can like click on
yeah and just watch should i see it from
the beginning yeah they can where they
can just click on whenever
oh okay okay
and i started over i guess yeah okay
what's up guys welcome to the just
prolly things youtube channel today i
have my best friend in the entire world
on her name is brooke
you want to say hi hi guys i'm brett
and she um we're gonna be introducing
her um hold on let me wipe off this
camera make it a little clearer we're
gonna be introducing her to like some
red tail concept and we're gonna see
like what she thinks of them so just a
little like background brooke literally
like
does not watch any of this stuff the
only thing she knows is like random
facts that i tell her from time to time
that's true
okay hi
and also if there's any concepts you
want me to like explain to her in the
like comments let me know and then i
will like do those as we go
okay
you ready wild look smile i don't watch
youtube
okay so do you know do you know what
hypergamy is
okay so hypergamy basically means that
like girls are always trying to like
find the next next thing
so like basically in the red pill um
they don't think like girls can actually
like love guys the way that guys can
love girls because
a girl will only love a guy like
that's like the best she can get but if
she has a better option like that makes
more money is more attractive is like
just a better all-around option she'll
leave her current like boyfriend or
husband for them
oh
do you think that's true or false
um i don't think it's
true in every case but i think that's
possible yeah would you say like
would you say like what percentage of
girls do you think are like that
i don't know okay this is just burgers
just like it's not exact like they're
not expecting you to like have stats
ready to go i'm just going to explain
concepts to you and just like from what
you've seen
talking to your like friends you can
just say if you think it's true
i know like
i just like
they want to like i don't know they like
being
like in a relationship i feel like yeah
i feel like they're not like looking to
leave because
i know they're always heartbroken when
so you're broken up with yeah yeah
no i think so um
i don't okay this is one analogy that
i actually thought was really true
i feel you're not actually not you but i
have a lot of friends um
that i feel like they have like an x
that they just like can't get over and
they call it like a widow
and it basically means like the one guy
they like pair bonded to so that
basically means like before like
evolutionarily like typically you're
with one person mm-hmm um or like they
pair bound to one guy that like takes
care of them yeah so
um and then it like ends
and like those girls like can't get over
them because i've seen girls like in new
relationships that like are still
thinking about like the last guy i could
i could see that like as being a thing
yeah
that's what i think too
um yeah i definitely have people that
like
feel like or they'll like compare new
people to their ex yeah
but i think it's like there's kind
there's a limit though like after so
many years they kind of like forget
about that you know what i mean you kind
of get done with it yeah
five thank you so much for the um
for the donation five dollars
you guys have good reaction
um okay what do you think about cheating
would you be able to work it out with
someone that cheated on you um
no because i hold grudges like no other
um so they'd like anytime they'd make me
mad i'd be like
well you cheated your ho
well because the whole um they have a
candy store analogy this is what someone
wants to explain to you
so basically like girls can hook up with
guys like have sex from like the age of
16 ish on you know
some some even younger some earlier with
like or older some younger whatever okay
um
so
i'm fine seriously
you can't you can't read the comments
okay
like
yeah yeah you can't read the comments
too like you can't
let them get to you i mean i'm not i'm
not worried about it okay
no it's like um but anyways so
she like
was gonna talk about the candy store
analogy okay so basically the candy
store analogy is like can't sex is candy
and girls get it right away but most
guys don't have access to sex until
their late 20s early 30s
um because that's like when economically
they built themselves up as a guy like
to the point a girl wants to date them
okay so if you get married like before
then they think that like
girls should put up with cheating
basically
yeah i know because like it's not fair
to the guys because like now at 35 they
finally put out their money right they
got to the gym for five years did all
this stuff now they get to have sex with
a lot of people so why would they only
settle for one well then why did they
get married if they don't
yeah that's what i would say i don't
know well they don't get married then
this is oh this it only pertains to like
the top 10 percent of guys like jay-z
like
like super rich guys
i just feel like they shouldn't get
married but if someone like
i know like if someone
like
if like if someone got married to them
and they cheated that's like their
choice if they want to stay with them or
not like
personally i wouldn't but then also i
feel like there's certain people that
you kind of expect to cheat yeah don't
marry them if you're not looking for
that yeah
um so they're saying that marriage is
for kids
but this is this is what's interesting
to me because they always say things
like men are only as loyal as their
options that's a really common phrase in
the mannosphere um and it's super common
for them to like believe that cheating
is different for men and women which i i
actually think on some level it is like
emotionally like verse visibly um like a
guy will have hook up with a girl and i
think it can actually mean nothing i
think that's harder for girls some girls
can do it but i don't i think that's
like the exception rather than the rule
okay okay did you feel true or false
um
i don't know because i feel like
i feel like it's changed now at least
like our generation because a lot of my
friends
like
are literally like they're not really
worried about
being in a relationship or they're just
like dating around and like not
too worried about it but i do like some
people can't do that like some girls are
yeah like they get mad if a guy's
talking to other girls even if they're
not even dating they're just like
hooking up yeah um
i this is like the way i see it i have
like seen a couple exceptions but i
think girls like become like that
because like
they're like older and like they've
hooked up with so many guys like each
one becomes less like
oh you know like but like a lot of the
girls i've seen that have like become
like that didn't start like that there's
a few exceptions i can think of yeah um
would you say that's like true fall like
you can say like freely if you agree or
disagree i don't i don't carry it away
no i think it's easier for girls to get
attached
but i
i think that also
says something really distracting oh no
i'm sorry
i'm interested in the coming but like
um
i think
girls get more attached
in short term
i think long-term guys get more attached
yeah that's a manageable concept yeah
that's true but um i think girls get
more
attacks short-term but i also think like
there are more girls than people think
that like really
aren't looking just to like date one guy
and stick with one guy like i think they
want to see their options first too
before like committing at least like a
lot of like my friends that i know
mm-hmm
yeah
no that's funny said the
um
the thing about girls get more attached
immediately and guys get more attached
long term because i agree with that yeah
because i think a lot of times girls
will tell guys like what they need and
communicate that and a lot of guys just
like don't do it yeah and then like the
girl gets so annoyed over time
she like leaves they call this hyper to
me but sometimes like i've seen really
because they think it's like hypergamy
to the point um
that the girl's just looking for the
next next option and i have seen that
but i've also seen like
girls that like tell guys over and over
again what they want and then they don't
do it well that's what my roommate
relationship was is like she told him so
many times like what she wanted
and then um
he just like never did it and then when
she left she was like right leaving
she's like we literally talked about
that
no guys
like he was so confused
um what was he talking about but it's
interesting because the menosphere seems
to think like
men um like don't have a biological like
girls have a younger biological clock
would you feel like that's true if you
want to have kids yeah because i think
it's like dangerous and you get close to
40. like yeah yeah
um which men can father kids like later
60s it's like wild yeah but i i think
that most like guys biological clock is
like 40 because i think a guy over 40
looks kind of weird if he doesn't have a
wife and kids
like 40 to 45. if you're still going to
the clubs and stuff like how about
that's like crazy what are you doing
yeah
you know and most people don't want to
have kids at 50 like
you know how old you would be when like
yeah i graduated
yeah
um
it is a dolly sorry i moved recently and
it was um
yeah i moved recently and my boss helped
me and brought it
um
and uh really like you can't have more
kids i just
watching my dad and how like tired he is
yeah and he's he'll always say like he
wishes he didn't have as many kids
i'm like dad you didn't you you don't
want us to exist
but my dad used to be like my dad used
to be way better at skiing than me and
now that he's in his 50s i can like beat
him so
it's like melted in the car
what is it what she wants a reasonable
and is she giving in return oh i want a
reasonable okay what are your let's talk
about your requirements for a guy
okay how tall does he have to be for you
to date him and how tall are you um i'm
five six
um
i don't know i feel like i'm not like
too picky on the height i do like when
they're taller than me though yeah like
for cuddle reason
yeah but what's like what's the minimum
the minimum well i know i think damian
was like five nine like you're saying
your minimum six two guys my minimum
no actually like her ex boyfriend of
four years yeah i don't think i've
actually dated anyone next over
six
but okay yeah maybe six months would you
date a guy that's um five seven
maybe
yeah so five times like iffy five five
nine is like more where your preference
is yeah i i'd say like
five eight to six two i guess i don't
know i don't want them super tall
um
okay and then what
is there a minimum like money
requirement that like clearly you
probably wouldn't date a guy dating or
making 25 000 a year
i'm i'm not worried about money as long
as they can take care of themselves okay
because i
um
i don't
like like i
yes
keep talking i'm reading it i'm gonna
ask you the questions
um now i don't have a minimum money
requirement as long as they can take
care of themselves because like i have
my [ __ ] together and i'd rather have
some of their shittily okay um so you
would you care if you did like 50 50.
would that be fine with you that's what
you did in your last relationship right
thank you yeah um i think 50 50 is like
for dating and stuff yeah yeah i think
that's fine um i definitely
gifts are not my love language so i
actually don't really
like when people like i don't really
care for when people buy me gifts
because i buy myself whatever i want so
i'm not so
i'm not i feel if we go on a date or
something i wouldn't mind doing 50 50 or
you pay one time and i pay one time
but
um
i don't know
as long as i can how old would you date
35 maybe
up to 35 yeah okay
um
so so your requirements is
like ish five seven and up
would you say
like i'd say forty five thousand and up
cause that's like when you can take care
of yourself like thirty thousand you
can't really yeah maybe around here i
don't know but yeah that's like 45 000
and up for income and then um
what's the third thing i said
high oh and age so under 35
yes i have to say i mean i'm not super
picky and all these i'm really anxious
yeah
they always they always say like girls
have these like super crazy requirements
and
you know i would say like i was probably
the most picky of all my friends and i
was so picky yeah i know i was
i was so picky but i didn't even have
like i didn't even think my requirements
were crazy because it was just like this
is like i would say i'm a little bit
more lenient now but when i was younger
it was like
um i wanted the same politics same
religion
taller than me
um motivated
yeah driven i didn't care about money i
just wanted them like driven
i think that's it right and then like
somewhat in shape
yeah
i just i think the main thing was um a
lot of times you didn't give
like a certain guy second chances
because no i didn't i was actually like
you just decided right away that it was
not gonna work yeah well because i'd say
oh like they didn't have that one thing
yeah but then like i don't know the
older you get you kind of realize how
stupid that is well everyone has their
flaws i feel like people are awkward on
first dates too yeah and i didn't
i don't know i was so lost in dating
though um before
let's see oh gosh
you smell cap on the
i smell like half of a money issue
they like never believe girls i don't
see that her boyfriend made less than
her of four years guys
um
okay wait
just to base pill
they don't want to have kids in your 40s
and 50s they agree okay especially in
this society
i should do a live music reaction no
this is going to be a red pill
conversation that's why i labeled it
this guy's just really just like he
doesn't like my answers
no they never do like that's the thing
you have to understand like with the red
pill like no matter what you say they
get mad like seriously
and like and even we don't have to date
dude yeah i know but and i don't know
why i don't know if it's because we
symbolize like
like
the average to cute girls that reject
them all the time so they get mad when
we say like we would reach out you know
what i mean yeah i don't know what it is
but it's just like
people people get so mad on the red pill
and i had to like train myself to just
not listen to it because they're so mean
like they're like so mean like they'll
be like oh she's just a four like
oh how much should i have deadlift okay
let me tell you i used to be really
strong
um i used to be able to deadlift
220 for five consistently
but um i've been struggling so
i haven't been lifting this money has
she cheated no you've never cheated on a
boyfriend no i don't
i feel like cheating is i don't know
it's kind of [ __ ] up
no
i i wouldn't have a reason i mean unless
you were really unhappy
[Music]
you i was like oh no she didn't answer
it quick enough
well they said what would the reason be
if you did yeah
[Laughter]
[Music]
well okay but this is the this is the
thing though in the um they consider
having guy friends cheating because they
think you're taking like emotional
like stuff from guys but go go get the
ice cream go see i'm gonna entertain the
chat while while they're waiting guys we
ordered ice cream and it takes like 20
minutes to get it
oh my god no no it's been it's been 17
minutes so we're okay
um but let me know what questions i
should ask her literally put them in the
chat and if you donate like i will
definitely do the question um
like for sure
but
but yeah put in the chat like what i'll
probably do anyway i'm gonna be honest
but i'm trying to i'm trying to make a
living out here
um
start singing i'd rather not
oh i will not do the body count unless
you guys pay for that because
i
i
i don't like it when people ask that
that's kind of like a personal
thing even if it's low like that's so
personal
um
okay
react to an alexander no guys do
questions
oh i'll ask her about girl body counts
versus guy bodies counts
um
see this is where actually so the 50 50
stuff this is where i disagree a little
bit in the minnowsphere um i would say
that
like in 2021 um
things are gonna be a little bit more
modern like i don't think it's ever
gonna go back to like that traditional
one person super feminine one person
super masculine like
whether we like it or not society is
evolving and things are going to change
um
i do think like we should go a little
bit further back to like the more
feminine more masculine maybe getting
married a little bit younger but
you know 72 percent of girls like work
so i think it's okay to like want to be
to contribute to an income and there's a
lot of girls that like
i know that are really motivated and
driven competitive and like want to work
um
does she know what men want okay i'll
ask that when she gets back
um
would a
5-7 guy need to have
to be in the game i think her
ex-boyfriend was five nine so i don't i
think five seven would be fine for her
things have changed and that's why dudes
um are not dating anymore
um
yes and no like i think dudes aren't
dating because a lot of guys don't have
the option to date like guys
why do you think a lot of guys are red
pilled and black-tailed and whatever
like because they want to date girls and
girls don't want to date dogs like
guys
act like
um
like guys don't want to date anymore
sure but like most girls if they wanted
a boyfriend could find someone to date
them
no matter like
how big they are how how like how big
they are how high of their body count it
like a lot of guys will say oh she's not
marriage material like it's over for all
these girls but like guys it's just not
true
maybe like the top 10 20 but like girls
should be happy with a guy in the top 50
and most girls can find one
um
sorry like hate to say it but there's a
reason like red pill stuff does so well
it's because men like want to date
um
sit in the back seat for better audio
you don't see this thing in the back
guys
um
most men are invisible to women yeah
that's what i'm saying so
like guys will be so judgmental on the
tail like it actually like makes me
sad sometimes because i have to read
comments about how it's over for me
because i'm like 24.
um yours came out first but i definitely
ate some
oh
gosh i wish you got a spoon
for you yeah and do you want me to get
you one would you mind
i guess
i would love to thank you
yeah let me try yours
you're so fire
okay
and this is the thing what women say and
what women do are complete two different
completely different things
this is what irritates me about guys
they'll say that and then i'll provide
evidence to be like oh her boyfriend of
four years was only five nine he made
less money than her and then they're
like um
well did it end like most relationships
end
so yeah but
um what type of ice cream
[Music]
the stuff is so good thank you
oh my gosh i got a little on my leg
this is not a red velvet comb
oh man they ran out that's weird
that's the only reason i got the cone of
the wizard off
wait someone paid money to ask you a
question
okay
what do you think men want
what do i think men want
um
i think guys well initially they're
attracted to kind of like what they see
so
i think guys
if they like the way you look it catches
their eye so if you're totally random
and they see you
i feel like that's what catches the eye
first
um but i think that
i think guys i think physical attraction
goes it's kind of like short ran
i know i think guys want someone they
can talk to
i think guys want someone that they can
talk to at some point but i think
it doesn't go they don't they're not
really as interested in that unless
they're
more serious about dating i guess okay
but i think physical attraction at first
um i think guys also
i think some guys
want someone they can take care of
financially or they want someone who'll
take care of them so like
do things around the house or like
cooking cleaning yeah like
deal
i think you can go either way
okay
um
no i haven't quit i worked out today
guys
actually i've been live right the two
times i ate junk food this weekend oh
yeah i didn't quit your fitness
um
i would say that's true um
like i do think like guys like to be
like
like not like taking care of a little
bit like they like to feel like wanted i
think and i think a lot of guys today
like don't feel wanted
um i can see that um i think i just want
a girl to like work with them
you know what i mean like to not like be
so compact combative with like
everything and argue with them about
like i think a lot of guys are really
sick of girls that like give them like a
headache
you know they just want to argue all the
time
i don't know is that coming
yeah
um okay
what are your deal breakers for guys
hmm
if they don't want to go
out and do things
i really i like i
feel like i'm active for the most part
and i
can't sit still very long so i like
people that are more adventurous or
spontaneous or proud
um because i don't mind just staying at
home but i also like going out and doing
things okay and then also someone that
isn't lazy i feel like i've been around
lazy guys growing up
i'm really not lazy
um
do you believe women want certain guys
in their 20s and different guys in their
third oh calyx introduce you to this
concept
maybe
i mean
because in your 20s you go you're just
you kind of think i want some really hot
guy
and you don't i think you don't have a
lot of other
you don't have long-term values in mind
and then in your 30s
you realize that maybe the certain guy
you wanted in your 20s
is actually kind of shitty
and wouldn't be a good long-term
relationship they kind of think
differently and what you want
that's literally exactly what the red
pill believes
that's literally like because they call
it alpha and beta oh girls go for alpha
have sex with alpha and then betas like
um it's what they go for in their 30s so
like the like more provider type
do we like the red pill um
yeah but it like pisses guys off because
they feel like they like girls will have
sex with like the alphas right away
but then the betas they'll like make
weight do all these dates do all this
stuff even though they're like having
sex with alphas behind their back
i don't know if i agree with that 100
maybe some people i don't think that's
super common
[Music]
okay
let's see
is cheating and cheating is a deal
breaker for me yes um i don't believe in
that because my dad is like in the
category of hive like high value man
in terms of like income
um
and he never cheated on my mom and like
she never had to worry about that
he didn't even like drank
so i think it's like a lack of
discipline if you cheat
sorry
and then they'll be like oh it's like
harder for guys not to cheat yeah but
like everything is hard
staying in shape is hard making money is
hard literally everything is hard so
it's like
why someone asked if i am a nurse during
communications are they trying to insult
me
so i mean they don't like what i'm
saying
i don't know
she's an engineer
um
this is the
this is what literally irritates me
oh um yeah right never got caught with
as many kids as he has there's no way he
went with without from nine months
you know you don't like you can still
hook up
and the other thing is like look guys if
you look at the stats over 250 thousand
dollars 50 percent of men cheat that
means 50
don't
like i i have no doubt that it's hard
for men not to cheat i have no doubt
that
people a lot more people cheat when they
have the option to like this is all
common sense
like i'm sure i'm sure if there's a way
to measure like hot girls the hotter the
girl the more likely she is
too cheap
um
but like
like you're gonna tell me like you can't
control yourself sorry i don't
um
my dad and this is this is how i know he
never cheated
like
even i asked my dad like i asked him
about situations where people cheated i
said do you think like as a girl if you
have a husband that like loves you i
asked him he's like no he's not a good
person why would you want to be with a
bad person
um
okay
just because 50
because there's fifty percent of this
this is fire thank you some positive
content
[Music]
exit um they put cereal in the ice cream
and mix it
it's like
but
that's like
well do you feel that generally speaking
men tend to cheat more the more money
they make
i think people tend to cheat more the
more opportunity they have so i
guarantee like
hot girls tend to cheat more than not
hot girls
um okay
when you when you asked your dad if he
cheated did he react the same way as
your friend
[Music]
it's just like
that's like the thing about the red pill
like once they see
stuff through that world view like
nothing can change the way they see it
so if i say okay
my dad doesn't cheat he doesn't do that
stuff like everyone will be like oh then
he can't girl get girls i'm like guys it
doesn't have half a percent of murderers
you don't think he could get a girl to
sleep with him
like
come on
um
so
[Music]
we're hotboxing
we all have options most of the time
it's just not usually the ones we want
fair fair
um
okay let me see what
else i'm seeing like what other
questions are in here
people keep asking me and why i might
like me and one year broke up
but
you guys i don't
just because people seem to seem happy
on social medias when people are in real
life
um
i also believe there's two different
types of rich people i think those like
corporate america rich people are
different than like small business like
i think that cheating is more prevalent
and like millionaires and [ __ ] that like
corporate ladder and have that like
power and the millionaires that just
said f everybody i'm gonna go start my
own business go on a piece of land and
not deal with people
i could say cheating about power power
too yeah wanting to have power with
someone
when do you want to be married by
i don't know i don't know if i ever want
to get married
if you were to get married woman was
trying to get married
i don't know like by 40 i guess
do you think that body count is
different for men and
women um
no
i don't think to me i don't think it's
attractive when guys have super high
body counts like i wouldn't really go
for them i guess if i knew of it before
um i think it's more normalized for guys
that have super high body counsel
but i don't think
i think as far as like dating wise
it's not super different
i think like girls are judged more for
it but i think that like there's
biological reasonings because it's like
historically like men wanted to know
that like
they're they're the kid they raised was
their kid
so if you have a super promiscuous girl
like that's why they're turned off
because they want to like ensure
i
paternity
yeah
um
men don't yeah um
yeah it's sector dependent how many
opportunities can you cheat if you're a
millionaire software guy versus a rap
artist in miami
um okay let's say your dad
um never cheated what would stop him
from doing it in the future
no i know because it's like it's like
unheard of to them to like know someone
rich that doesn't cheat
like to them like
rich people just cheat that's just how
it is oh
um
let's say your dad never achieved what
stops him from doing in the future i
just know my dad my dad would get
divorced if he wanted if he wasn't happy
he would get divorced like my dad
i don't want to put it like he just
always like
like
it's like weird because he's like the
most religious pers like least religious
person i know that has like a really
strong like moral compass
you mean like he doesn't drink how many
people do you know that don't drink have
never drank yeah like he's never smoked
weed like he's never like he doesn't do
anything you know he just works
um
um guys my dad would not need a
paternity test we all look just like him
um
most rich people i know don't she i i
agree actually oh why should we be put
in prison
um
oh wait i should have no freak we should
be both people in prison
um
can your dad loan me okay okay five
dollars 95 of women on dating sites are
modern women who aren't submissive
um coincident
wait coincidence or valid reason
um
maybe because
they're not afraid to go after it so
they can kind of judge guys based on
looking for i don't
like you saying they're not submissive
so like they're probably more
like dominant like
95 of girls on dating apps aren't
submissive so what do you think yeah oh
well
that's not true it might just be the
girls that you mess with
like okay i actually don't know the
background
i mean i just like do you really think
95 of women on dating apps like actually
aren't submissive or is it the girls
that you're matching with
like just realistically like what
percentage of girls do you think are
submissive it's probably a higher
percentage than you think
like me okay
um
guys we're not smoking weed
don't do drugs guys um
yeah most people are religious and
wouldn't you my death's not religious um
okay
you should be controlled and given to a
man
interesting okay
okay i cheat once a week right you know
what i can't do
um okay if you guys if girls
if a girl wants to keep you around
she'll be submissive i need people to
define submissive because i was thinking
about this the other day
um
because like
a lot of times they'll talk about in the
manosphere like a girl should be
submissive to a guy and that just
basically means like the guy makes the
final decision
so like um
like because at the end of the day in a
marriage like someone has if you guys
disagree on stuff someone has to make
the final decision
but and why do you say that though what
do you mean by that because okay if you
guys have a disagreement and like you
have to pick like what you're going to
do i do have a whole dollar in my
backseat
like if me and you have a disagreement
right and we let's say we're married
right
like we have to like one of us has to
get our way and one of us won't why why
can't you just compromise that's what i
would say
like i would say like sometimes it goes
one way sometimes you go into the mother
and sometimes you compromise like i
don't i don't know if i believe in like
100 submission but i do think like men
are more naturally more logical so like
i would probably be more up to like let
like my future husband like make more
decisions than me but like i think it's
like silly to say that you're never
gonna compromise in a marriage
i
think that people i've dated have not
been more logical than me so i would
disagree with that because i wouldn't
care if
sorry experts i would care about their
opinion yeah but i wouldn't
i
i if it's something i felt really
strongly about i think it would be
something that we should talk about but
i think if it's something that you don't
care about as much then it's easier to
be like to prevent a fight you make a
decision because it's not important
um
a husband has to love it
submissive just be agreeable and let the
man lead
um
i don't like that word word personally i
like cooperative i like the word
cooperative too because that's what like
i think like a marriage is like you're
both like i think he's saying like the
woman should be cooperative though i
think it should be in a marriage you
just communicate but like the point is
you want to marry someone that you trust
to like you so like that's like the goal
is you want to like find someone that
like you trust like make those decisions
i like my own decisions yeah well i
think that's where me and you would
probably differ like yeah i would be
more apt to say like you know i'll let
my husband decide on stuff and i don't
think you would be as much oh no
um okay
oh do you know anything about alimony
laws
um
a little bit
do you think like men and women like do
you think men have a bad deal when it
comes to marriage it will ex actually
the person who pays alimony is the
person who um usually makes more and
most of the time in older divorces it's
the guy because a lot of times the woman
didn't work
so like katy perry had to pay uh russell
grant money she made money more money
than him so
alan's bad
um you don't think like i think the
court system stacked against men though
like in terms of like child support and
like even just like custody cases like
ninety percent of the time it goes to
the like to the woman do you think in 90
it's like like when you genuinely think
about it like i don't think 90 percent
of the like if we look at a popular full
population women are better parents
ninety percent of the time it doesn't
make sense well that's what i think the
thing is um is that
eggs determine right so i actually know
people who their dad got custody
like a decent amount like people that i
work with well i'm talking about like
statistically though well yeah
statistically it was like i think the
woman either i think that they give it
to them because i think the woman is the
first option because it's their mother
yeah came out of them but if the woman
can't take care of them then it goes to
the man so do you think it's like do you
not think that the courts are stacked
against men at all i mean i haven't
really been involved and i feel like i'd
have to see it yeah be involved in it i
can't really yeah
that's fair enough like you guys she's
not in the red pill so she doesn't like
listen to this stuff
so it's like
you know you're asking her question like
she's not gonna yeah have stopped
readily available um okay
women oh do you think that like um
because women can get in a like a woman
can like terminate a pregnancy do you
think a guy should be able to sign his
rights away
like at the same time
to a kid yeah so like if if a girl can
say i don't want to be a mom and captain
abortion and the guy has no say in that
right do you think a guy should be able
to have like a financial
like be able to say you could send the
rights away to a kid you just don't sign
the birth certificate
i don't know i don't know about it
yeah if you don't want to take the care
of the kid then don't hear the kids
um do you think paternity tests should
be mandatory um
no
i i i don't think so i think that'd be
kind of weird
just for someone to take a virginity
test okay oh i don't know do you
um
i think paternity tests
i wouldn't be like opposed because i do
think like sometimes girls cheat and
they have no idea like the guy has no
idea and then like like i've heard of
people that raised kids that weren't
bears
so i could see like state mandated
paternity tests like
to be like kind of controlling the
governments yeah yeah
i understand like and like you're paying
taxpayer dollars for other people's
mistakes so i don't
i don't have a strong opinion on it you
know i could see both sides uh i think
that i don't think paternity check
should be mandatory but i think that
birth control should be more accessible
to people to prevent stuff like that
i feel so accessible you know like yeah
i know but i'm saying that like i think
it like not like i don't know if now it
is it used to not be yeah i'm just
saying you could go to plan b get like
50 bucks
but i think um okay
women
um okay
let me look at other questions in the
chat
why not
paternity test mandatory well we're just
saying like it's an overreach of the
government and it's like kind of against
human rights i don't know well and it's
like what if you don't want to take it
like then are you gonna go to like
there's more to it yeah but like i i
don't care
if i had to take one like
um
okay
no um
okay
sounds like permission
likes rushing into cheating and waiting
i'm pregnant i work as a counselor birth
control okay do you think i think if a
girl gets pregnant nowadays it's her own
damn fault like i genuinely think like
we have plan b we have condoms and we
have birth control
both of people's fault oh yeah yeah but
i'm saying like like um
i don't really have sympathy even if
you're low income for getting pregnant
because it's so cheap and like so
accessible now yeah i think that i mean
if you can't afford to have sex like you
you shouldn't yeah i think both the
people's fault i just think that people
always blame women no matter what yeah
extend their body
well i mean i think it's i think it's
more of the girl's fault than the guy
because it's a girl's responsibility
like to be on birth control so
why is another guy's responsibility to
wear a condom oh it is yeah i just think
i'm saying like i don't think it's just
more of the girl's fault like the guys
can usually wear a condom and those are
more accessible than well
with them but the girl can also make the
guy wear a condom like like assuming he
doesn't like you know do anything he's
not supposed to do like you can say like
no we're not having sex without a condom
yeah i don't know i don't think i would
just wouldn't say it's like more of a
girl's fault because i feel like a lot
of times younger people pressure
like other people
um
okay
her body hurts okay whatever um
let's see but it's your responsibility
yeah yeah it's 50 50.
yeah i don't know i'd probably say it's
six people you're responsibly not to
open your legs
he's just saying
i didn't have to say it like that but
like basically you're just saying like
abstinence if you don't want to get
pregnant like you don't have to have sex
well yeah that's an option but i'm
saying if someone gets pregnant it's
both people's fault because most people
did it
um
i mean
uh do you think that
is your friend aware that it's harder to
have children the older
[Laughter]
do you think that women control access
to sex men control access to
relationships
um not all the time i guess maybe
sometimes but
do you think the majority of the time
um
i don't know because i think that just
kind of
sounds like
men just assume all women want a
relationship but like why do you think
you're so special that all of them want
a relationship with you i don't know
i think most girls like i think the like
from what i've seen like i think the
majority of girls like want a
relationship yeah like the majority like
the if i had to like survey 10 friends i
know about like if the guy they wanted a
relationship with the guy they're
sleeping with i would say like eight do
and again i think my friends are very
different than yours yeah i think my
friends aren't like that but yeah yeah
um okay
um
okay someone donated five dollars
um marriages become a taxable entity as
of 1913 and anything that is connected
to the sector is set set up to castrate
men
um
is modern times
yeah she doesn't like study the
paternity laws so she did or divorce
laws i'm not right about a divorce
[Music]
majority
um i actually don't think the majority
of girls want relationships with the top
20 of guys because they never factor in
the 50 of men like 50 of men are in
relationships so it takes out half the
guys
um
um
but yeah so i i would say it's more like
the top like 40 percent of guys or 30.
um
hey my brother's name is chad and he's
delightful
no oh my gosh that's the word they used
to describe like no i know i tell him
that all the time
yeah
[Music]
okay
do you both want children i do
i
don't right now at least i don't think i
plan on getting kids or having kids in
the future
um
okay most women aren't even aware that
they are sleeping with the same guys and
they're part of a rotation i would say
that's true like i don't think most
girls under the age of like i said under
a certain age don't know that but like
also like unless you're
i don't know i guess
i feel like unless you're concerned
about it who cares i guess i don't know
i don't i don't think i think most girls
like aren't going to be cool with the
guy that's sleeping with like other
girls oh like in general
um
i don't have a master's degree or a phd
communications or nursing
not either
she's an engineer guys
um but they would share ten percent of
men
and then settle for the yeah that's just
like how they see the world i've seen
guys i've seen some girls sympt
over some broke ass dudes that are not
cute have you not seen that
um i definitely have seen it yeah just
like why are you i'm like they always
think it's like the alpha chad but i'm
like you would be surprised yeah you
would be surprised there's this girl i
knew in college right
and she would like cheat on her
boyfriend with this guy that like
literally was going nowhere he was short
and i would say like he was good at
flirting but that was literally it that
was all he was good for and she was like
cheating her boyfriend all the time with
this guy yeah well i know girls that
sent for guys like um the guy they're
dating will like cheat on him all the
time and they'll steal some from and
you're like why do you want to be with
him no i know and they're like some
loser like this one girl in college she
was literally taking care of him he
didn't have a job she was taking care of
him and he was having sex with her girls
in her house
and this is the thing they always think
it's like the chats or these guys are so
hot
i'm like guys it's not like
i literally
[Music]
um
okay
that broke dude is a chat why is he a
chat
then everyone's a goddamn chat
um okay what is the importance of men in
life in society i think men are really
important to society and in life um i
think that like
if you want to get something fixed
generally like you either hire a guy to
do it or you ask like someone you know
that's a guy
um
[Music]
he was hurt chad oh
hey how much did they what no i'm
telling you these are like pretty like
well-rounded girls
like that i'm thinking of anyway the
girl that i was remember the guy that
was living her house she was in a phd
school
like she was a boss she was going she
was going to be a um ot was she pretty
and like then
um
i think i think so actually i didn't
meet her in person she's my friend's
friend oh you didn't know okay um
an exception but this is this is my
issue like i got sometimes the comments
make me so mad not even mad but like
like
if you say okay that hasn't that's not
lined up with what i've seen they're
like oh that's an exception not the rule
i'm like okay well then why are you here
like asking like watching my thing
um
okay
do political views matter um they matter
to me because i'm really political
i think they matter but i'm not super
strict on it so we can have
disagreements but as long as we're not a
dick about it i like would rather date
someone that's either not political or
the same like i wouldn't care if he
doesn't care about politics
um
i'll take notes an average guy doesn't
have a chance
didn't we just say how bombs like i
swear to god yeah
um
okay
oh my god
ask her if she thinks do you think you
could live if you if all the men
disappeared tomorrow
um
yeah i think i could
i mean i live on my own right now do you
mean like and like do you think that
like i like okay i don't think society
would function if men disappeared
tomorrow
because they run too many industries
that keep men going and like they
wouldn't be able to transfer the
knowledge to women like that like it
would take women too long to learn those
industries
like because there's so many industries
that are like 95 percent men when it
comes to the infrastructure of society
[Music]
i don't know 100 because i think it
wasn't common for women to be in those
type of industries before but i think
now it is so
specifically i'm talking about like
power plants plumbing yeah
it's like construction you think is all
men but i i'm i have a two
i have the world's largest con er
construction
company and like another really
giant-ass one
that are my subcontractors and so i go i
face i do face-to-face with them a lot
and a lot of them are women yeah i
wouldn't expect that you know i know but
i'm saying like like brooke if we looked
at like like i've just heard the data on
this too much so like a lot of times
like girls don't really think about this
stuff because like
like why would you you know what i mean
well i mean i'm involved i feel like a
lot of that i really am interested i
know but i'm saying like i know but i'm
saying like if you look at the data of a
lot of these industries it's like 95
percent men so it's five percent women
when it comes to power plants
electricians
plumbers bricklayers
those like industries run
so like i'm talking about more of like
tech school jobs yes
um so like i'm saying like without power
society would collapse
yeah but i think that there's another
woman in it that can teach other women
like i wouldn't think it would be a huge
issue but i mean maybe it's an
adjustment to find people to fill their
spots well that's what i'm saying like i
think it would be to like people would
die off before that like happened
because like 90 if if 95 of any industry
what was wiped out it would collapse
well because no one's going to be able
to have kids so it wouldn't even matter
well yeah
yeah yeah no no no i agree but i'm
saying like in this scenario like it
doesn't like they're not talking about
reproduction they're just talking about
like running society yeah i mean i think
i disagree with you yeah no i mean
that's fine
um
and like
uh
okay where are the other questions
do i know that 30 of guys haven't had
sex in the last year what has to do with
me
are you gonna go sex with them
like sometimes sometimes i think the
manosphere wants you to have like pity
sex with guys
like they're like oh sex sometimes i
love the manosphere so people think i
like i hate it i just have disagreements
with it
um
oh my god
let's see where we go
oh my god okay
hook the homies up who don't get
um
not true
well guys they literally say if you
don't have sex with someone on a first
date like
to like leave like call another girl
like they're they're they're literally
red pill dating advice that say that so
oh like do i do i think they demand like
and like they say that's good advice i'm
like why would you force it like
yeah just jesus
um brooke do you make guys wait a
certain amount of dates to have sex or
would you have sex on a first date you
don't have to answer that if you don't
want to write a camera i have sex on a
first date
um okay
even if this channel um
even we
okay black pill is for zero to four red
pill eight to ten
uh
that's because they're what what do you
think is the difference between a guy
you would have sex with on a first date
and a guy you would make weight
do you think it's just like the
atmosphere or do you do you think it's
like the guy
um
i think it depends on my mood and then
also like
how you feel i guess on the date so like
i guess like atmosphere and then like
sometimes
i mean something if you go on a date
with a guy you already know does that
count because then you kind of know
their personality already and like i
agree with that yeah i would agree with
that i think that's common if you
already know them and then go on a date
like after a little bit you kind of know
their personality and can feel it out
there um
i don't know i don't really would you go
on a date with someone that you wouldn't
have sex with on a first like that you
wouldn't want to have sex with or would
you go on a date with them
i mean
i feel like i would go on a date with
someone if i'm not even even if you're
not instantly attracted to them that
doesn't mean you can't go on a date and
see if you
like their personality you know yeah
that's the i would say like sometimes
like you're not sure like yeah maybe
like they're kind of like
like
somewhat attract you know what i mean
like you're not you're just not sure
and so like they'll be like oh don't go
on a date with a guy you wouldn't have
sex with i'm like what if i don't i
don't know i might yeah well also kind
of i mean not rude but sometimes hey if
you just shoot someone down um right
away and then never give them a chance
to go on a first date i don't know
that's gonna
why date if you're wanting to get
married
what date huh to see if you wanna marry
yeah like i'm i'm looking to get married
um
cool if you're not sure you can pay
so you're saying that's like
constitutional
someone you have
no this is that's oh my gosh that's my
biggest disagreement in the manosphere
like they tell girls to have sex so
quickly and i'm like guys like girls and
they say they don't like girls with high
numbers yeah and i'm like girls
literally release chemicals in their
brain when they have sex with someone to
bond more than men because men's
testosterone like blocks it you guys
can't have it both you can't have
someone
to have sexy on the first date and then
get mad when they slept with a lot of
people
um
okay
oh god i dropped it um
where are we
uh
no bro guys can be a snake like once
they get your goods it's a done deal but
not all this is the type of okay
okay
yes found my name wrong ebony at the end
would you consider abstaining from sex
before marriage i actually like
that would be my ideal situation to be
honest but
like i think it's kind of hard to find a
guy that like that wants to do that i
think it is so so i'm like i yeah it'd
kind of depend what he would want to do
um
[Music]
but like yeah i think i wanted to do
that i totally would
you probably wouldn't right
i just can't imagine you doing that
um okay
stop basing your manosphere views on
fresh and fit and kevin samuels are kind
of niche they're just like the biggest
ones i've seen
um
[Music]
no i actually think that
most guys don't care as much about body
count as the like manosphere thing i do
too yeah
like just some
people around me in their relationships
and the like relationships i had i also
don't think it says bigger deals like i
i think i think older guys care more a
little bit yeah well like like the old
school yeah but like honestly like
this center yeah this generation i don't
think so um what do you think women
on average and aren't interested in
statistics about the dating market are
they busy yeah why would you look up
stats if like you're happily dating
um
okay question for you what can you learn
in two to three years of dating that
would prepare you for marriage wouldn't
it be easier if you just married your
guy and you're one no
i disagree with that
um i don't think you really get to know
someone until you learn
i think living with them helps a lot and
then also some people can kind of
suppress the bad parts of their
personalities for a while
so i think after a certain amount of
time that can you see it really start to
come out
um i actually would be okay with
marrying a guy in like six months
okay no i'm saying i was like
yeah like i because personally like i
think like there's risk regardless like
i think like it's not going to mitigate
that like regardless you're not perfect
they're not perfect there's [ __ ] that's
going to come out when you're married so
like
maybe not six months i'd probably say a
year like i could date someone for a
year and then i think a year makes sense
especially i don't know
um
let's see
here's the test what's the difference
between men males and
and boys
um i don't i don't know how's my name
wrong again yeah it's brooke with an e
um i would say men i think of like guys
that are like established males is just
the gender and boys is like
like immature guys yeah
yeah i agree with that um
they're getting married um
so statistics say that living with
someone forgot about australia really
should be more than but if you marry
you're gonna
live with them yeah so like why not
figure out this way if you're compatible
or not well because actually jordan
peterson explained this in a way because
when you live with someone like you're
both saying to each other
like oh we're not sure so i'm gonna kind
of have like one foot out the door in
case it goes bad which isn't like
which when you like just make the choice
to get married you're saying let's like
try to make this work like forever
so like statistically like it makes
sense to me that one would be better
okay
um wait
okay
are you bored if you're bored like they
can go
um i'm not worth
maybe like 15 times okay
um
okay
you bristle laughing okay
[Music]
rebuttal your friend if it doesn't work
out why waste three years of your prime
year for all years especially if you
didn't have a child with your live-in
boyfriend
well we'll be smooth
i
am not worried about having a child
right now so that wasn't a concern for
me
um i just really liked being around them
so i wanted to keep dating them and
you're not like you don't even know if
you want to be married yeah so it's like
different for you
um oh [ __ ] okay
oh god oh no what did i do okay
um do you know
uh yeah i knew that but i don't want to
talk about that
um
did you know divorce
women divorce 80 to 92 percent of the
time but a lot of times like the number
one cause of divorce is um
it's people say it's finances but it's
actually not it's actually like
like
infidelity so
like i would say a lot of those girls
divorce their husbands because they
cheated on them
that makes sense uh i feel like your
vows are supposed to be uh
you're in the arse of first
oh interesting
damn
oh my god i've not noticed
[Laughter]
they want you to buy a dog and die alone
oh
i'm not as much
more of a cat person i actually do
really want a dog i've never had one
i don't think i'm ready for one of them
i'm not home enough
okay to give you uh to give
he thinks we're great save your king
you're great
thank you
okay you won't know a dude until you see
how he handles a rough financial spot in
his life
i get to see that i think i think it's
good to see people when they're really
angry to see how they deal with anger
or like just in every kind of emotion
see how they deal with it um
okay the number one i've i've heard like
if he had money infidelity wouldn't
matter
yes of course a certain percentage of
people marry rich guys for money like i
don't know why this is like shocking
oh yeah
of course
it's an art that was rude
that's so rude
it's rp rage oh so they're saying you're
rageful because you're like
understanding the red pill
i don't know what that means
um okay
what advice would you give to a guy that
wanted to approach you like what would
be the best way to approach you
i don't know i'm so bad at telling those
guys they're flirting with me
um
i would say do it like
be casual
i think they ask you like a question
yeah make it more of a conversation
like
if someone asked me like oh what do you
think of like what's good on the menu or
something
and then like just kept talking to me
after that you know what i mean like an
easy opener where i don't like
so i get nervous if there's too much
pressure on the conversation
yeah
i don't know
i think yeah as long as it's more casual
be tall and handsome that helps
yeah being tall and handsome yeah i mean
like duh just like being a supermodel
would help you approach guys
like duh
um
be a top 10 percenter
yeah like does that help i mean it gives
you an extra yes i guess like i don't
know why
it's like okay if a girl has huge boobs
a big butt and looks like a model does
that help
yeah like but guys want to be so mad
when it's like money the opposite way
around like yeah
people like superficial things that's
not crazy
nothing's right but like they're
superficial people duh they're gonna be
attracted to superficial things
um
someone said you have a cute smile and
you're pretty eyes yeah oh hello
oh what's your number one fear in a
relationship mine's getting cheated on i
do not want to get cheated on oh well i
guess
no i'm not gonna say it
my number one period relationship
um
maybe if you
you like
someone falls out of love with you when
you don't see it coming i feel like it's
kind of oh that's a good one yeah like
what would be that happening and then
they like actually are falling in love
with another girl
that like
or a guy marrying you because he's your
second choice and he couldn't get the
girl he actually wanted yeah that's not
a good feeling yeah
um if your future husband has a net
worth of 10 million
and he cheats okay look at guys
i have a heavy trust like
i don't say i have a decent amount of
money
like i'm sorry um okay a lot of women
when they like super short guys
we are super sure with guys in combo do
you see this even on the male side
guys being super short as women um
even when they like guys are super short
in combat i'd say shy girls maybe but i
think i'm a girl with you she probably
doesn't like you yeah and i think guys
do the same thing to like fat girls like
aggressive no i'm serious like you can
see the way they treat like a pretty
girl versus like a girl that's
overweight
like it's not it's not nice but it's
like just a reality you know
like an obese girl walks into a room
like the guys are going to be way me
like not as pay much attention to her as
they will like a supermodel
okay okay it's just like people are
superficial um
do you think indian men have it worse
than the dating market if they're
unattractive yes
i think if anyone sounds on track today
but yeah there's like hot indian guys um
i have a friend that's 400
411
oh god that's so hard
he's just dealt a bad hand
would you date a guy 411
i don't think so yeah
um i let
we would treat our big girl like one of
the guys
um okay guys well i think we're
why is being short so bad girls just
aren't attracted to it i mean some some
are it's just like more rare yeah it's
just not a
like it's just is what it is it's like
guys aren't that as attracted to
overweight girls in general there are
some are but like
like
that's life
um
okay well guys thanks so much for
watching i think i'm gonna end the live
now this was fun did you have fun
i had fun
it was good thanks for hanging out guys
i've never done this before this
yeah so a lot of these concepts are like
new to her so don't like
guys please in the comment section
please don't like roast her she's never
like
you can roast me i will never see it
because i don't watch you too
yeah you know fair enough uh but she but
seriously like she doesn't like research
stats all day like half the guys do in
the middle sphere like i do
i read contracts all day yeah
um but let me know in the comments what
you guys agree with what you disagree
with don't forget to subscribe to the
channel bring that notification bell and
i'm going to talk to you guys next time